[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau c'est 8 le journal nous
sommes le 31 octobre sommaire la
toussaint est un moment important pour
les fleuristes chrysanthèmes et bruyères
s'arrache pondre hommage aux proches
disparus nous pourrons à pointe sur
cette journée et puis direction bois
d'arcy pour un tournoi de volley assez
particulier vous allez le voir il était
organisé ce dimanche neuf équipes
étaient toutes déguisés pour l'occasion
nous irons aussi à poigne et la forêt
découvrir une fontaine légendaire qui
serait habitée par des faits focus sur
cette légende à la veille d'halloween
mais nous débutons ce journal avec un
nouveau rassemblement nocturne de
policiers en colère vendredi dernier à
versailles ils étaient 250 à manifester
devant le château tous en tenue civile
ils ont manifesté pour certains avec
leurs brassards et d'autres exhibant sur
de simples feuilles blanches des phrases
chocs policiers en colère touche pas à
mon flic ou encore policiers sacrifiés
délinquance protéger le but de ce
rassemblement dénoncer leurs conditions
de travail l'allocation d'une enveloppe
de 250 millions pour l'équipement des
fonctionnaires annoncée mercredi dernier
par le ministre de l'intérieur bernard
cazeneuve n'a pas altéré leur
détermination on passe un sujet plus
léger en cette veille de la toussaint
les fleurs sont à l'honneur chez les
fleuristes chrysanthèmes et bruyères se
vendent pour embellir les cimetières une
tradition vieille de cent ans qui évolue
avec le temps
reportage faisant commerçants de
montigny le bretonneux de nicolas kérino
vite et nicolas bandes qu'elles soient
rouges jaunes ou encore orange les stars
de la toussaint ce sont elles les
chrysanthèmes flore de tonnes pour
décorer les cimetières une tradition née
au lendemain de la première guerre
mondiale pour embellir les tombes des
soldats morts pour la france et près
d'un siècle plus tard les chrysanthèmes
reste numéro un des ventes même si la
tendance évolué ces dernières années on
a quand même de plus en plus de demandes
sur des plantes différence sur des
hellébores sur des choses qui vont
vraiment tenir tout l'hiver
par rapport aux crises en table 6 mai à
faire froid il n'y a pas une grande
retenue coin ne faut pas jane mais de
plus en plus et puis beaucoup de
compositions différentes varier la
plante quand même que l'on vend plus
serait ce le chrysanthème mais par
rapport à il ya quelques années c'est
vrai qu'on vend autre chose avec la fête
des mères la saint valentin et les dates
traditionnelles le week-end de la
toussaint est l'un des plus importants
pour le chiffre d'affaires des
fleuristes qui n'hésite pas à développer
leurs services pour répondre à toutes
les demandes et en ali clients qui
viennent spécifiquement pour des
chrysanthèmes et aussi pour les tombes
ont fait beaucoup de livraisons dans les
cimetières donc on a beaucoup de
personnes six de province qui nous
appellent pour qu'on puisse kipré salle
destombes donc il y a quand même une
nativité muet différentes aussi bien en
magasin quand livraison chaque année en
france 20 millions de pots de
chrysanthèmes sont fondues à la
toussaint un marché qui ne devrait pas
connaître la crise de sitôt
place maintenant au marché de la
création l'événement était organisé ce
samedi à versailles les badauds ont pu
découvrir des bijoux fait mander jouets
en bois ou encore de la porcelaine il y
en avait pour tous les goûts et surtout
pour tous les budgets marché de la
création un reportage de anne-laure
l'anguille est
difficile de ne pas sortir son
porte-monnaie devant tant de belles
choses le marché de créateurs qui s'est
tenue samedi à versailles était
organisée par l'association la
révolution du fait main on pouvait donc
y trouver des lampes des bijoux de la
vaisselle des jouets ou encore des
cosmétiques uniques et originaux la
révolution du chemin
pour nous ces deux mots forts la
révolution et le fait main soit parce
qu'on a envie aujourd'hui de montrer des
petits créateurs sont là qui font des
choses uniques la manifestation qui a
regroupé une soixantaine de créateurs
surf sur le retour de l'artisanat dans
les habitudes de consommation face à
l'envahissement des grandes enseignes le
fait main porte des valeurs en phase
avec notre envie d'authenticité le vrai
travail manuel pour moi c'est un vrai
travail à forte valeur ajoutée c'est
quelque chose dans lequel on va mettre
vraiment tout son coeur tout son amour
c'est quelque chose qu'on fait combat
que le vote pour l'acheteur participer à
un tel marché offre l'opportunité de se
procurer des pièces uniques d'affirmer
son propre style raison d'hésiter qui
globalisent beaucoup de choses et qui
uniformise aussi beaucoup de choses
c'est à dire que voilà on peut tous
achetés à très bas prix de la mode et du
design ou des accessoires et que je
pense vraiment qu'on soit on a on a un
réel besoin de retour aux faits main à
l'authenticité a rencontré les créateurs
du lien de la convivialité et des belles
pièces la recette a bien fonctionné à
versailles l'association la révolution
du fait-main souhaite d'ailleurs
organiser d'autres marchés de créateurs
dans la région
et on prend la direction de magny les
hameaux le chemin de la chapelle fait
peau neuve des travaux sont actuellement
en cours pour l'abattage de marronniers
les arbres implantés depuis des années
risquent d'endommager le réseau enterré
et certains se sont animées avec le
temps le trottoir sera ensuite
modernisée avec des chemins piétons une
mise aux normes pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite
fin des travaux prévue samedi 5 novembre
halloween sand ça ne se passe pas que
dans les boutiques ou les soirées à
thème les sportifs célèbres aussi à leur
manière la fête exemple avec ce tournoi
de volley-ball déguisé à bois d'arcy où
s'est rendu notre journaliste nicolas
deuil
dans le royaume des morts vivants et
autres créatures effrayantes
il ya aussi de la place pour l'amusement
pour s'en rendre compte il fallait
participer au tournoi de volley ball
organisé dimanche dernier par le club de
bois d'arcy loup garou revenant et
autres personnages aimable se sont
affrontés de part et d'autre du filet on
a beaucoup de costumes un petit peu
improvisée en général de manière
plus récurrente on a assez dracula vous
en avait un sur ma droite qui est en
train de jouer et après les fantômes et
des squelettes difficile de dire qui du
fantôme ou du squelette ce match au
mieux de toute façon aujourd'hui la
victoire du match ne semble pas être la
récompense la plus recherchée pour le
meilleur costume en fait on a fait une
petite statuette pour répondre et
récompenser le meilleur costume et en
plus le vainqueur aura un ballon de
volée cette année et se déguiser pour
jouer au volley n'est pas la chose la
plus aisée il faut savoir user pour
garder toute sa mobilité le parc anger
non joués a répondu un costume ça va les
bains ne tiennent pas très bien la
perruque je n'ai déjà enlevé
on reste effet empêché
chaque année on essaie de trouver un
autre déguisement dernier j'étais en
zombies cette année chez un vampire
c'est avec ma copine on essaye de
trouver un costume pour nous deux quoi
pour être assorti c'est bon enfant et
puis comme c'est du loisir forcément on
joue le jeu quoi petite pause déjeuner
bien méritée pour nos villes un héros il
faut tenir 21 points pendant un match au
final du suspense et du rire de quoi
nous donner envie de venir défier ces
créatures maléfiques l'an prochain
et savez-vous que des yvelines regorge
de contes et légendes et bien c'est le
cas dans la commune de poids ni la forêt
et de sa fontaine miraculeuse la source
serait habitée par des faits et alors et
été
et interrompt du magic pas certes un
magicien un reportage de nicolas landry
[Musique]
selon les récits médiévaux des faits or
est élu domicile dans ce lieu situé à la
sortie de poids ni la forêt une histoire
surnaturelle tout droit sorti du
moyen-âge l'oratoire saint fort situé au
coeur de la forêt de rambouillet serait
magique lafontaine d'un mètre 90 aurait
aussi été témoin d'un miracle aux
alentours de l'an 300 l'évêque de
bordeaux traversant la forêt des
yvelines rencontre un enfant
avec une paralysie infirme donc de là il
fait jaillir la source et il se il a
vite l'enfant à se baigner dans cette
eau et l'enfant ressort guéri une eau
miraculeuse fêtée chaque année par les
habitants de poigne le jour de la
pentecôte les habitants se retrouvent
autour de cet oratoire restaurer au 19e
siècle nous demandons à notre père
robert de venir pour faire une
bénédiction donc il y à un pèlerinage
qui est effectué et nous nous célébrons
ce miracle auprès de la fontaine il ya
auparavant une messe à l'église de
poignet et de l'église
jusque-là fontaine saint fort les gens
viennent à pied poignée vraiment célèbre
par rapport à ça cette fête est aussi
cette fontaine une légende vieille 2016
100 ans qui n'a pas pris une ride et qui
continue à fasciner des milliers de
visiteurs chaque année
merci de nous avoir suivis et surtout
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]